many students attending camps this
summer will rely on school buses to get
there a CBS News investigation explores
the lack of federal regulations in the
process to find school bus drivers there
are nearly 22,000 school bus crashes
every year on average about ten students
are hurt each day Kris Van Cleave
investigated the dangers associated with
the people who drive your kids every
morning Kris good morning good morning
since school bus drivers are hired by
individual school districts oversight
can vary widely our investigation found
it can lead to problems that run much
deeper than traffic accidents when
you're raising a child you know your job
is to make sure nothing happens to him
this father who asked we not reveal his
identity struggles to even talk about
the day in 2015 when his 15 year old
daughter was taken to this hotel in
Chattanooga Tennessee and was raped by
her school bus driver our CBS News
investigation found on average at least
once a week a school bus driver is
arrested for I caught it big whiff of
alcohol driving under the influence and
what was on that computer child
pornography or sexually assaulting a
child for many it's not their first
offense
it was shocking shocking to find out
that you know the record this guy had
the girls driver Alexander Rodriguez had
a previous felony conviction for
possession of drugs and a weapon in a
school zone a background check
determined he was ineligible for hire
but he got the job anyway we found many
examples of drivers hired in spite of a
history of dangerous accidents felonies
or multiple duis like this driver in
Wisconsin arrested in December for
driving a school bus while under the
influence of drugs her third DUI charge
parents really need to be asking who's
driving their children
Steve Kirsten is a transportation
attorney he says federal safety rules
that apply to commercial bus or truck
drivers do not apply on school buses
because school districts are exempt from
driver qualification hours of service
and vehicle maintenance regulations why
do we require drivers to be safer to
drive lettuce to stores than to drive
our children to school
no National Statistics appear to exist
on school bus drivers who are charged
with breaking the law so we reached out
to every state to get them only
Connecticut and Delaware track all
drivers arrested on the job and while 21
states told us no bus drivers had been
arrested for DUI in the past three years
we obtained 39 police reports from those
states showing otherwise hiring enough
drivers is not easy
last year 90% of school districts
reported a shortage of bus drivers in
part due to low pay split shifts and a
lack of benefits Durham school services
which hired Rodriguez operates in 32
states and turns to Craigslist to find
applicants even cold-calling former
drivers I got a phone call from the old
job they were offering me my job back
because they were short twelve eighty an
hour you can get up here quickly
Kelly Shayne Hooper took a job in Kansas
while under investigation in Texas for
multiple charges of child pornography
and since many districts contract out
operation of buses
school officials often do not even know
who's driving as the principal explained
to the Father in Chattanooga he said you
know if someone were to kill the bus
driver on the way into the school and
just hijacked the bus and drive up we'd
put the kids on because we wouldn't know
any difference Patrick James
Frederickson did steal a Utah school bus
in 2015 a convicted sex offender he was
out on parole on the bus a list of
students and their home addresses he
even tried unsuccessfully to pick up
some of those students
it could be Beth Frederickson was
arrested Rodriguez pleaded guilty to
statutory rape and was sentenced to
probation leaving this parent demanding
more be done at what point do you say as
a society we need a higher standard
there was one very disturbing piece of
video in that story the boy on the
bicycle he did survive the bus driver
stayed on the job after that crash now
some members of Congress have proposed
efforts to better regulate school bus
drivers and those bills all died in
committee in recent years all of our
requests for interviews were refused but
the industry says school buses are still
the safest way to transport your
children to school how did you do all
this reporting we had to go state by
state
and put in multiple records requests are
my really wonderfully talented producer
Megan - II it was hours and hours of it
in some cases you would hear the
Department of Education for example in
Pennsylvania so we have no reports of
bus drivers being arrested for DUI
State Police then gave us reports of
school bus drivers being arrested for
DUI the pre law yeah very very team
thank you it's such a rite of passage
writing the school bus and to think that
like what he said you give more
attention to people driving lettuce and
you do your children that's that's very
very shocking
thank you guys messed up thank you Chris